how's it going there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here and it is time
to check out one of the most if not the
most anticipated show of the new year
it's time for the last of us but before
we get to that I am joined by the
wonderful the incomparable our good
friend Tara Ericson Tara how are you
today I'm good you're good you're good
good do you know anything about this
nothing nothing you haven't played the
game nope you've seen a trailer nope
cool this will be the noobs reaction to
the last of us I am very excited I have
also not played a lick of The Last of Us
so this could be completely fresh
experience
as always if you could leave a like on
this video that would help a bunch that
lets YouTube know what you like and
what's worth watching as well hit that
subscribe button and notification Bell
to get notified whenever something else
new comes out that you might enjoy as
always if you want to get the full
experience with us sync up with your own
copy come on over to patreon.com the
real rejects watch The Last of Us us
alongside Terror and I alongside Greg
and Andrew as well as all the other
bunch of shows we got over there with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included that was so much so fast John
good job I did my best ring that
[Music]
ring the bell I always do that on here
for the real rejects because it helps
you guys to ring the bell I know it like
you hear him ring the bell whatever but
drop the graphic in again yeah but then
you hear me singing you're like
definitely subscribe definitely I think
we're I think that's I think we're ready
now um my soul is is on fire let's do
this let's watch the show
[Applause]
and that's your biggest worry yes any
kind of virus but most probably
something similar to influenza
meaning all the whole world becomes
sickle at once oh so familiar many
species know otherwise because there are
some fungi who seek not to kill but to
control
like cordyceps or All My Exes so it
begins to devour its host from within it
keeps its puppet Alive by preventing
decomposition
fungi cannot survive if it's host's
internal temperature is over 94 degrees
but what if that were to change the
world was to get slightly warmer
well now there is reason to evolve
and there are no treatments for this no
preventatives no cures they don't exist
it's not even possible to make them but
none of this is going to happen
I'm terrified
I'm like how much of this is based on
actual theoretical science I feel like
probably a lot of it
and are we gonna see every single one of
those extras come back as a zombie we
might be dead in like two years creature
or whatever's about to come my God
climate change if we die I mean I'd be
happy to be zombies with you that would
be fun or whatever we become you know
like a zombie virus rattled hosts
fungal controlled Meat Puppets
[Music]
it's a beautifully disgusting Sim yeah
this is very cool
[Music]
it's like Game of Thrones but with a
virus
yeah
HBO's got a style
oh that's right what Craig Mason where's
the pancake mix what was that he's gonna
make you birthday pancakes I swear you
know I don't really like pancakes what
Oberyn Martell doesn't like pancakes is
there enough for our uncle Tommy I'm a
what a man hey stay alive yo
I'm not splitting his job I barely want
to split it with you you could work a
double today I know I'd be done by nine
by nine right
p.m bring back a cake
I promise you better keep that promise
he's not gonna
wish I had that kind of cash when I was
that young yeah right it's like a
treasure chest oh it's not hers got it
she's stealing
I wish I had a knife like that when I
was that young
Connie was asking that for you I could
come by after school but just for like a
little bit but she'll take what you got
foreign
I want one of those cat clocks
[Music]
oh
I'm very sorry he cannot finish I'm
already finished he's home
yep just send her alone out into the
world yeah
it's the math of salvation
you're right there
oh
no
no
[Music]
my dad's gonna be back real soon I
should go
uh oh she's not gonna be okay oh
oh
the dog knows they always know yeah
yeah it was off so they're good at using
backgrounds and focus
to drive up the Arenas the like ominous
like you know something's coming
Good Times ain't nothing bad gonna
happen today
where's the cake
come on man let's get this one tomorrow
you don't get your present you got me a
present that's it
fixed it for you
did you what oh
[Laughter]
far from the adlers oh this is the one
with the deleted scenes
me yeah but I'm in jail
out now it's Friday you don't get me out
tonight I'm in here all weekend
oh boy
law enforcement and emergency services
are in the area and we'll be in contact
with further instructions oh my God let
Mercy in though yep oh my God yeah let
her in
oh buddy
listen to the dog yeah please listen to
the dog
come on let's get you home
cool
oh no
a little Mercy
Mrs Adler
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh my god
wow whoa
what are we doing Joe I mean
nice hit
no no why why do people drop weapons why
baby I'm sorry Joe we gotta go upstairs
listen we're gonna be brave
let's go come on grab the wrench yeah
I'm so frustrated please grab the wrench
uh Something's Gonna no thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa It's Jimmy's Place
oh no you can't help anybody
oh that sucks
and then they'll say that somebody else
will come along and then that's somebody
else will say that somebody else will
come along
[Music]
oh my God everybody's gonna cut through
the Mexico just far as far as we can how
much
time to pick up the highway on the other
side of the blockade then we're out I'm
so tense right
what's up
oh that's why
oh my God no are they headed towards the
air what the
[Music]
oh my God
what Jesus
are you serious just keep going
oh my God
[Music]
I have Goosebumps yeah
[ __ ] move
move
oh my God
oh my God
[Music]
a nightmare
[Music]
are you okay are you okay
we gotta get off the street
oh my God
holy get out of here Jones close on me
okay you don't look anywhere else
oh
yes
got the neck Creek
oh God
close the door oh God
oh no
oh my God oh my God
performance on the show
oh my I love the irony of chasing them
through a diner oh
[Music]
don't move
our two civilians by the river one of
them injured yes sir
yes sir no uh okay yep yep okay veteran
combat make some moves now
yeah get closer
we are not sick
good thing that hill was there I'm sorry
please stop oh my God
oh thank God my man Uncle Tommy MVP
okay
[Music]
what oh shoot oh my God
no I gotta get you up okay I gotta hit
you up I know baby no no I know I know I
know I know I know I know Tommy help me
oh come on come on come on
come on
oh
what
20 years
[Music]
we got a [ __ ] kid over here
oh God okay wow
I said seems fine closer it is to your
head it's gonna be a little tickle right
here
oh
what if I told you that after we gave
you some medicine we're gonna find you
your favorite food to eat and then we'll
get you some new clothes and toys
as many as you want to play with in
heaven you're safe
body for the pile body for the pile ah
wow
oh
buddy God that's gonna be like PTSD for
him yeah
look good with the salt and pepper
though
I hope he still has his watch and the
battery lasted 20 years
I wonder if that symbol was some kind of
Easter egg
oh my God
oh
come on
now look more suspicious
prison rules
hi Dro stay off the streets for the next
few nights bosses got us working doubles
guys are jumpy and tired stay safe yeah
you too ugh
in the darkness look for the light oh
yeah
oh yeah I want you to forget this ever
happened done oh my gosh do uh you're so
discipline them I don't care they're
your [ __ ] guys
so I give you my word that he won't hurt
you so are we good
oh
my God
oh hello oh my God jeez
[Laughter]
e
oh my God
oh oh no oh [ __ ] they're shooting at us
let's get our hands up dude oh my God
count slowly and clearly from one to ten
one
two
three
state your name slowly Veronica hey
people are gonna come looking for me
people from cedra you hear me let me out
or you're gonna pay mother
woof all right I like her I'm on her
side
dude her name's Veronica in clear
tribute to Resident Evil Code Veronica
nothing is there any chances coming in
at night when I'm sleeping Gabriella
listens or my son the smart one not the
other one
Tommy responded we'd know
when you're talking to the Tower every
day
all right it's the Cody Tower qbar4 but
I don't know exactly what
[Music]
Craig Mason loves his deep focused
particulate shots
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about and now
get a trench coat and put them each in
there oh heck yeah his watch is gonna be
in there yeah with the battery taken out
and then he's gonna put it back in
I hope
clever girl
[Music]
oh yeah take a drink every state line
you cross
oh that's too many that's always alcohol
no
I was in Federal
oh damn Let's Go Hunt that mother down
yeah and get our battery and our truck
and then we'll go find Tommy
yeah is a cutthro world out here we are
in a war against a military dictatorship
to restore democracy and freedom to the
son of our right Rebellion 's time five
or 20 years and you get nowhere you're
not a rebellion
spray paint
I want them as distracted as possible
because tonight every Firefly in Boston
is going to gather in this building and
we are going to leave the QC we're
taking that random girl locked in that
room West
huh
where are you gonna go back to Federal
military school they put me there when I
was a baby it's for Orphans they didn't
put you there
United
Ellie what
oh
do you have a greater purpose than any
of us could have ever imagined but we're
leaving tonight and we're taking you
with us is she like immune is she like a
carrier or something what I'm about to
tell you cannot be related to anyone
you
do
this will go well foreign
what is that
Jesus that's the virus
whoa
whoa he came down after he was infected
maybe down here is where he was infected
that is good disgusting and beautiful
yeah just like the opening credit sure
smell that
yeah gunpowder
oh good
yes
oh I was literally about to say maybe
your buddy killed himself or was killed
oh
damn that is an important car battery
oh interesting oh no I
oh
Marlene
the merch was bad and he obviously
didn't take
my knife what do you need a car battery
for
dope not at her
oh whoa
she's special and now we all know it
we're gonna move Ellie out of the Zone
tonight but we won't make it anywhere
like this not for a while anyway
you're gonna do it
but now I don't have a truck I don't
have a squadron Federer's five minutes
away what I do have is you and I know
what you're both capable of
she seems desperate Firefly vehicle
usually means repurposed Venture stuff
you all talk it through but please
remember that I'm bleeding out
she's great
we'll go to your crew at the state house
but before we hand her over they give us
everything that we want if not we kill
her there and then deal that fast
I want to fill him in on exactly why
she's so special also I'd be like can I
have your gun because you're gonna die
yeah
maybe a couple guns
you just lost a whole Squadron you must
have some spare guys
[Music]
is probably more before times culture
than you've seen in your whole life
[Music]
so
you're saying like wake me up before you
go go
[Laughter]
the 80s
80s means trouble
code broken
he went through that billboard book and
found the first 80 song you find
look at the left edge around the buffer
zone
you stay close you follow my lead
yeah yeah of course
it's not gonna go well I feel like we're
gonna see the little girl being more
useful than they think with her little
knife
yeah she's going to take down a whole
Squad of fedra soldiers
I love how they have that Mantra about
looking for the light and now the light
is like the most threatening thing
let me put it back in real quick damn it
oh it's him it's a friend
you're gonna be shitty
really man yep the game is by the book
oh no oh no
no fine everything off of this run and
half off on all of the pills half off
all off out here in mine
yes [ __ ]
okay uh
don't no no
oh
[Music]
yeah oh no come on
yeah he's gonna have to beat him to
death damn
bummer given the harsh circumstances I
kind of like that guy but also I get it
he was also the only help sort of oh
yeah no no no I'm not saying explain
[ __ ] I tell your story Girl
take his gun it ain't Christ
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's a fun needle drop
cool shot wow oh wow
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that was that was so fun yeah insane and
so good I'm hooked and Dreadful and and
ominous and and so well fleshed out wow
that's a PTSD yeah yeah yeah a little
bit of PTSD yeah yeah
oh boy
well Tara Erickson yeah what did you
think video game expert Terrace yeah
yeah uh well just real quick last video
game I played was left for dead does
that game still exist that's how long
ago did remember that game I did oh in
fact I've played a little bit of leopard
managed to play a little bit every
zombie game except this one such a good
game uh wow this was amazing great
actors great casting uh and oh yeah
great story the only thing I'm mad about
is that he left the wrench behind
because I don't know I mean that could
have come in like why no like wipe it
off and put in your back pocket that's
like a weapon you could take you know
come on now don't worry in episode two
he'll see a different wrench he'll flash
back to that rent that will make me
happy and also why would you leave the
only other thing why would you leave the
alcohol other than that this is a
brilliant show obviously I'm just saying
I got a couple of notes you gotta get
the yeah you gotta get the major
complaints out of the way before we heat
praise upon them a couple of notes
that's it that's about it everything
else Wow real good yeah have you did you
see Chernobyl yeah yeah this is the same
Creator show runner I mean you know Neil
druckman who uh you know did the game
and all that stuff not solely obviously
to oversimplify Neil druckman is like
the major uh you know contributor to the
game working on the show but yeah Craig
Mason is yeah the guy who did Chernobyl
among other things and like Chernobyl
was pretty incredible to my viewing
experience and I thought you know like
okay it seems like a good choice for you
know the vague amounts I've collected
over time about what this world is
supposed to be but yeah like the way
that this fleshes out the situation and
lets you live inside of it and and
really kind of puts you in a uniquely
there's like a unique blend of like very
realistic grittiness but also this sort
of like ethereal sort of melancholy that
that you know touches everything and uh
yeah like
again I don't really know how to I can't
compare this as an adaptation but this
does feel this has to be like I I can
only imagine people are going to be like
this is the best video game
because this does completely feel
cinematic yeah if this was a video game
I would play it which I guess it is but
it left me wondering I'm like whoa so
what's the game like you're just going
around negotiating and like trying to
get car batteries and like occasionally
having to shoot something but mostly
just like dealing with the aftermath of
society oh and uh hydrocodone too yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
filtering for drugs pilfering pills I
kind of want to be the guy in this video
game or in the show that is just making
bullets and making pills right because
that's chill you're like you pop one
you're chilling you're making bullets
making pills nobody wants to kill you
because they're like you are important
yeah and I need pills I need to yeah I
need to go numb and I need tall summer
or something yes yeah well we'll get to
what do they say Atlanta you know oh
yeah maybe because I I have to imagine
if they're traveling outside of the
quarantine Zone we're only that's only
gonna get worse and we're only gonna
spend more time away from what should be
an easy destination yes
she didn't pick back up her knife that's
another thing right because she did she
stab the guy at the end in the leg with
her knife I think the shooter guy right
I think she did I mean in the hallway
scene she goes back into the room to get
her a bag but I think because he kicks
it up the hall but but we didn't see her
like maybe they just we'll see it and
what knife was that I'm mad when they
don't get weapons back these are the
importance these are important I'm
learning a lot of things about your
tastes taste as a viewer it's good
never leave a weapon anytime ever ever
you're the character in the video game
who's like why can't I hold more like I
imagine you're playing a video game if
there's like DLC you're like you're just
always throwing down for the expanded
inventory yes there's hundreds of items
because you just said they're going it's
gonna get worse and I'm like yes and you
want to see her do some stuff with her
knife she's a tough girl but then I'm
like did she leave it behind
I hope she didn't she couldn't he at
least
yes he did yeah she also knows how to
kick butt you know like she's like right
she went to military school for a minute
it's gonna be good yeah it's gonna be
good well dude like the way like they
really had me going because like that
Pro you know like I feel like it's a
it's a classic type of I keep calling it
zombie but I guess the more apt term
would be like infection outbreak thing
but like yeah you know you have your
sort of prologue where you're like ah
yeah you're like in society and
everything's normal and then we meet
like a family but only one of them is or
the whole family's not gonna make it
through and I thought the way that they
did the whole prologue was really
intense and affecting and like they
really got me invested in Sarah
especially the his actual daughter
oh yeah and that whole like mad rush
through the city where they're in the
card it's not like one hole there are a
lot of long takes not one whole take but
the way they captured them in the car
from mostly just that perspective like
it hit me part way through I was like we
have not left this car and I am so short
of breath because it feels like you are
kind of in the midst of it and I Marvel
at the idea that you know after so many
of you know this kind of thing something
can still feel as fresh and vital in
depicting you know the the the the day
Society collapsed you know as as this
felt and then the subsequent time Jump
you know and they did a good job with
just the very subtle like the bumper
sticker of like he's a combat veteran so
you know that they're they have to prep
they'll make it right but you you don't
see it coming when they're it's like
safety in that car with that logo and
them being tough but you do not expect
her to be ripped from that situation so
quickly uh again just like the the I
this you know the happenstance is so
heartbreaking because yeah it is one of
those things where you can you encounter
one soldier and if you know you don't
handle the situation right or they get
the right order you know like things are
gonna go south and yeah the way they
captured that like
God and I also thought this is not it
but I was like could Marlene be that
girl who died her mom like 20 years I
was like they never established who the
little girl's mom was yeah and when I
saw Marlene come in like being tough and
I'm like well there was no pictures
either in the house yeah of what the mom
looked like but now the mom's dead so it
wouldn't be they wouldn't set that up
for like Marlene to bleed out and die
because she was sure
if she died she had one of those wounds
that you that those are like she's
standing and she's like completely over
here you know like I think she'll be
okay okay then I'm gonna I'm gonna keep
that in a side pocket and say Marlene
could maybe be revealed to be the little
girl who died her mom all right
did a thing one time you know but
Marlene was like I gotta get out of here
can't have the kid you get it that's why
they know each other okay I'm done now
she walked out on them both damn
she's like I gotta do military stuff
that's right she's even in normal
society I gotta lead the Rebellion I
gotta you know reinstate democracy
and her rescuing the girl is her like
making up for leaving her child I got it
all figured out just like the show put
me in the room you know the writer's
room don't just need to watch more
episodes but you just did it yeah you
should be writing season two I don't
want to just let me be in it yeah no I
mean this would be this would be one of
those dream shows where it's like even
if you just show up for like an episode
to be a female character who will then
be killed or something I've been under
I'm okay with it right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so let me up uh yeah I
mean and the casting across the board
like Pedro Pascal I think is great
um I love I I hope we see those Diego
Luna I think as as Uncle Tommy like I I
love it he'll be back yeah like I hope
to see him again and uh and yeah like
there are a bunch of other actors who
like you recognize and were some of them
from Chernobyl because I'm bad at
recognizing that but I'm like Chernobyl
also it totally makes sense when she
brought that up was such a brilliantly
acted TV show that and that's just like
uh I love it when shows are like I
believe everything that is coming out of
everyone's mouth and that is not
normally the case always yeah and like
the like everybody really plays
everything with a very lived in quality
like you know I feel like in a show like
this or a movie that you know is doing
post-apocalypse and stuff like that I
feel like there can be in the dialogue a
certain amount of like posturing whereas
here everybody does just feel like this
is the day in day out like the lines are
thrown away in just the right ways where
you're like yeah no I can tell you're
sick of this [ __ ] and you can't give out
too much information and so you know
like that scene where um Marlene is with
her like lieutenant or you know the
other woman who's helping her and then
she sends the other two guards away it's
like yeah it's like the first time we're
meeting the both of you but I'm just
like fully invested in like the conflict
that you're dealing with and how I know
you can't like Marlene can't give up too
much information because clearly no one
in this world is very trustworthy for
good reason right and the way even just
that they draw that Society like I loved
meeting oh what is her name Tess in in
that moment where you know she's
bargaining to get out of this uh oh yeah
yeah the the two guys roughed her up and
she's like bargaining to get out of that
situation and then immediately tells
Joel about it and they go back to find
him so good yeah and just like the chain
of events because you know it it made
this for this really nice feeling that
just the plot is unfolding and every
plan leads to you know every step of the
plan kind of diverts in a New Direction
because the situation is such a mess
that I have to imagine no plan is really
like foolproof or not subject to a lot
of variables that could change it up and
it feels it it nicely feels like a world
where yeah they just kind of have to
deal with whatever [ __ ] situation
they're dealt at the time rather than
feeling like oh the plot demands that
such and such a thing happens right and
I feel like in that situation Marlene
and her like Lily I forget what that
girl her name was not Lily when they're
in the room she sends the two guards out
just in the way they say their names to
each other she's like Ellie and she's
like Marlene like it's just so it's
great and it's already established like
great we're they're a little bit closer
than the rest yeah we get that and just
with one word it's like bro you gotta
open up to me now because this is some
[ __ ] uh which I really I really like
but it's the same thing with Tess when
she was with the guy it was already
Within a sentence or two establish like
that they kind of knew each other and
there was a way that they were gonna
sort of bargain for her to maybe get out
of there yeah that scene was really
really enjoyable yeah and very funny
hilarious this whole show is Left Right
but yeah and and like I love that little
prologue I wonder if we'll see probably
not I have to imagine but I wonder if
we'll see like you know they got John
Hannah and Chris overdahl and that guy
from Silicon Valley in the opening scene
where they're really laying out like
here's a discussion of exactly the
situation we're about to deal with and
uh and yeah too just I don't know
there's so many nice little flavors
across this that it I have to imagine
that now by the end of this episode
everything is set and and we're you know
striking out into the unknown the ruins
of society but I have a feeling that
that'll be kind of
you know this episode gave us a few
different times and places to deal with
before you know sending us off into the
main part of the story and I also love
that you know this is coming out of a
horror like a survival horror game you
expect yeah there will be a lot of you
know horror set pieces and infected
creatures to deal with and I like the
way they handled the Restraint of that
for this episode as well because you get
certainly intensity and violence in
moments of you know a huge chaos and
Peril but we really have yet to see the
full scope of the actual infection at
work you know you see that guy baked
into the wall and everything but how did
he get that way that's a thing and
they're like he they probably got it
down there right but they're not
answering there's we still don't know
then why are you not running out of
there yeah they must they know something
that we don't like how do you get it how
do you get the virus oh I love that too
the whole like you know if it's on your
your head or your face it'll be like 15
to 20 minutes yes yeah it's like it's
like an arm it'll be like an hour if
it's like your foot like 12 hours yeah
yeah they're really great at laying in
details and building the world in a way
that doesn't feel like we're getting
like the moments where you have like
that argument between Marlene and her
general or whatever like that's a bit of
exposition but it felt very well
motivated by like the frustration
between the two of them and I think that
for a lot of the stuff they have to lay
out they're really good at making it
feel like something characters would
naturally be talking about rather than
telling rather than setting up a reason
to info dump the audience yes and so it
seems like something you do have to pay
a certain amount of attention to because
they're not just going to force feed you
everything but it also seems like if
you're really paying attention it's all
there you know yeah yeah I hate shows
that are like overly ex expository
that's not is that that is right I said
it right people yeah okay
like a good like Exposition in a show
but none of this felt that way to me
except for yeah the setup of like how we
need the girl out we're gonna use her
right and we need to move but that was
more like oh yeah like okay cool like I
didn't feel I felt good about it I was
like I didn't feel like it was
exposition of us already knowing that's
the thing I hate it when we already know
something and then they feel like they
gotta double check and let us know in
words what we already know yeah uh I
hate that and they didn't do that and
then so I'm I like me likey Yeah Yeah
man they left us off on a little note of
trouble I love that too I love the code
with the radio yeah and I was trying to
figure out is it 70 so it's new because
60s is old was that a 70s Vibe and
there's like something new is coming in
because I feel like that girl did decode
stuff but that was like yeah I don't
know was it any I feel like the last
song must have been an 80s song for to
signify this onset of more trouble okay
I mean we already knew that we're sure
we knew more trouble maybe it's like
there's more trouble now there's
something new on top of the trouble new
trouble and there's no way we can find
out what era the song was from no
there's no way I like rewind it let me
Shazam it real quick yeah that's right
that's right Shazam will sometimes I've
tried shazaming things from TV on
occasion and instead of bringing me just
the song it'll bring you to the episode
of TV yeah and you're like thanks that's
not what I'm trying to do when it does
that yeah I'm like I need to know the
song and the artist to go and listen to
this song forever and always in my
vehicle and when it gives me like this
is from the show just listen to the show
in your car and and you know try not to
be distracted but yeah I love the world
they set up here and and I feel like you
know we're venturing out from there so
we're not going to spend all the time in
the camp but even like the camp was
super interesting and now I just can't
wait to see what lies Beyond
so uh I think we did it was there you
got any more stray thoughts
oh did anybody else leave a weapon
behind
oh yeah I already said it in there he
should have taken her gun because she
was bleeding out but like we said she's
gonna come back she'll be back and then
that girl is gonna look cool with one
ear she is right that's gonna be she's
gonna look so badass yeah so yeah I'm
stoked on all of it yeah me too well
guys leave us your thoughts leave us uh
don't spoil anything if your Gamers out
there you can go comment on Greg and
Andrew's video not ours so don't you
know we we ask respectfully that you
share your enthusiasm Enlighten us on
anything pertinent to this first episode
but uh yeah no game spoilers or anything
like that we would like to preserve the
surprise of this experience us noobs
gotta stick together so uh thanks for
joining us if you joined us and hey
let's let's send this off with a patron
of the day shout outs that's all good
yeah
Gabriel I'm choosing you because Gabriel
Luna is in the show and I love Gabriel
Luna Gabriel oh Gabriel oh you're cool
Gabriel oh
[Music]
yeah yeah it's not in a LOL he's in a
high cause he supports a big tree on
that's the end of my song cause it was
really bad
wish I was more talented when it came to
improvising songs dude it's hard right
it's hard it's hard but Gabriel you know
what's not hard appreciating you being a
part of our patreon page I hope that you
like spooky things you know we always
hope you know because it's always a
little bit random who makes it onto a
shout out but I hope that this is the
show that's up your alley so that we can
share in this together so that you
didn't have to sit through I don't know
if you notice you can't skip ahead on
YouTube so you just have to sit through
you know 40 minutes or so of us
yammering and reacting to get to his
Shadows so Gabriel thank you for your
patience and uh stay safe out there
don't take don't contract any odd
infections you know oh and don't leave
your weapons behind Gabriel you have one
job to do
and and staying pledged to the patreon
yeah
I mean indefinitely would you say don't
leave your weapons behind man we don't I
don't want to get mad
at you or friends doing Gabriel me and
you are friends out you know unless
you're leaving weapons for us to find
yeah yeah sure sure like I scavenge your
amount of weapons I would love that dude
you're good Gabriel thank you for the
scavenger hunt thank you so much buddy
love you
[Music]